okay good morning um class so we are
today
doing um the rise and fall of the Roman
Empire and this topic is extremely
relevant today
because there's a country in the world
that
purposefully model
itself um out of Rome and this country
is the United States of America the
similarities between
Rome and United States it's very
striking um both of these societies were
of their time the most powerful
Nations Rome dominated the Western World
for centuries and today America is the
world's most powerful
nation in fact America is so
powerful that if the entire world were
to get together
decide for whatever reason to invade and
attack
America and not stop until America was
defeated well if that would have
happened America would win America is
really Invincible it's protected by two
oceans and it has infinite resources and
it has an extremely aggressive
population and the world's most
sophisticated military
um so by studing in Rome We Gather
insight into America where America is
right now in its history and where
America is
headed and the central argument I will
make to you today is that both of these
societies Rome and America are really
war machines they're extremely
aggressive and if they cannot turn their
aggression
outwards they turned their aggression
inwards um Rome throughout its history
was either fighting Wars against its
enemies and then when it ran out of
enemies it fought Wars um within itself
which ultimately led to its Decline and
collapse America is in a very similar
situation um after the fall of the
Soviet Union um in 1991 America became
um hyperpower it had no comp crators it
has no peers in the world um even though
it tries very hard to look for enemies
for example for the past 10 years
America has been trying to paint China
as new
threat America really has no
adversaries and as a result it can't
really
um be aggressive abroad so this will
lead to if the history of Rome is an
indicator it will lead to a massive
Civil War in America in the next 10
years okay so that's what the history of
Rome tells us okay so today I want to
look at three questions the first
question
is why did Rome rise what allowed Rome
to become an Empire a superpower of its
time the second question is what did
Rome ultimately Decline and fall the
third question is what is the legacy of
Rome what is the impact and influence of
Rome in today's world okay let's look at
the first question so Rome the tradition
we don't actually know this true or not
but the tradition is that Rome was
founded in
BCE and from for that early history Rome
was a monarchy it had a king then in 509
BCE it became a republic not democracy a
republic and
then and at that point Rome was very
much a poor backward and
isolated City along the
Tyber and at that point in its history
no one okay not even the Romans could
have predicted that in 300 years time
Rome would become the master of its
world the Mediterranean okay so um to
understand why Rome was able to succeed
let me very quickly draw for you a map
of the world the
Mediterranean um in about 500 BC when
the Roman Republic was founded so um at
the center of this world was really the
Persian Empire the Persian Empire was in
control of the of the world's three most
most prosperous regions Egypt Anatolia
which is modern day turkey and
Mesopotamia which is mod day Iraq and
these are the three most fertile regions
of the Western
World um it was extremely prosperous
very heavily populated and the Persian
Empire was in control of all three
regions okay so the Persian
Empire um is like
this a cross the agian and the
Mediterranean from the Persian Empire
are the Greeks you had Athens and you
had Sparta okay and these were the two
dominant uh city states or we call
polish uh in on the Greek
mainland um across the agatic is of
course Italy um and the dominant power
actually in Italy at this time are not
the Romans but but but a culture
civilization we call the truskin and the
truskin for the longest time were
dominant over the Romans in fact some
people believe that Rome was originally
a colony of the ausans and the First
Kings of Rome were actually rusian
princes
okay um and then over
here is a place called Carthage which is
an emerging
power okay
and over here above the Greeks are the
macedonians so these are the major
cultures and powers of that time now one
of these Powers will eventually
Dominate and then provide the
cultural framework for all wor
civilization and if we were to go back
in time and we were to analyze this
situation
then we could make some predictions okay
our first prediction would be that
Persia would eventually conquer all
Europe right because Persia had infinite
wealth it had infinite um resources it
was a superpower that was intent on on
aggression okay and in fact as we know
eventually it will launch an invasion of
the Greek mainland okay so if we were
to predict or guess who would
dominate the
world we would think it would be
Persia that's our first guess okay but
let's just
say then who's who be second well we
would think that either Athens or Sparta
would be second why because Athens has a
navy and it it is a really powerful navy
and at this time Greeks ization it's
really
growing okay so we would guess Athens or
Sparta and remember Athens has a Navy
but Sparta is really um a military hamon
it is focused on being a military
Powerhouse and it has really the best
military in Greese at this time so our
third guest might be Sparta then we
could guess um Carthage
why because Carthage is strategically
located in Northern Africa which gives
it access to all tra roots in Africa um
over here um into all of Europe and then
back to the
Mediterranean okay so carage would also
be a good guess we would not guess
Macedonia okay why because Macedonia is
a poor backward King Kingdom North of
Greece that's being controlled right now
by the Persians we would never guess the
macedonians but then there's one one
city that we would never ever
believe could dominate the world and
that's Rome okay Rome would not be on a
list Macedonia might be on on the list
because it still has a strategic
location it has a very militant
population but would never ever guess
Rome
now what's funny about these predictions
of course is that
eventually Rome does conquer the entire
Mediterranean world and it
becomes uh the superpower of its time
and then it develops the cultural
framework for all restan civilization
okay but not only that but close to Rome
is Macedonia because remember Macedonia
is where for the second builds the
world's most powerful military and where
actually the great comes from to conquer
all the Persian
Empire okay so it's very strange that
the Nations that either are not on the
list or at the Bott list will eventually
conquer the world all right and this
goes back to our first class where we
talk about the oceanic currents of
History how Empires are destined to fall
to decline in but in the process the
enter energize these Borderlands and
Empower these Borderlands to rise and
eventually over time to overwhelm the
Empire okay so this is true for
Macedonia and this was certainly true
for Rome okay so this fits into our
pattern of the oceanic currents of
History what I want to so there are many
different reasons why Rome would
eventually win out over its competitors
in the in the
Mediterranean what I want to focus on
today are the cultural reasons so my
argument today is that Rome in
opposition to its enemies developed a
cultural system that allowed it to
triumph over its enemies this cultural
system made it ideal for military
competition
against um the its major enemies
okay
so let's talk about this cultural system
and to understand this cultural system I
will compare and contrast it with the
Greeks who are also um who are basically
the most culturally dominant uh people
in this area at this time okay so what
do the Greeks believe in well the Greeks
believe in three things okay the Greek
system or when I mean Greeks I basically
mean Athenians okay um because the
Athenians were the culturally dominant
um uh nation in the Greek world all
right so what what did the Greeks
believe in and and how were the Romans
different well first we understand is
that Greeks were culturally dominant and
and so what happened was that Romans
developed a lot of their cultural
systems in
opposition to the
Greeks or they learn lessons from the
Greeks okay so think about as analogy
the relationship between China and Japan
a lot of Japanese cultural systems and
values were developed in opposition to
China and because of the lessons that
the Japanese learned from Chinese
history
okay so um what let's let's talk about
the Greek values and then what what
values the Romans develop in opposition
to the Greeks okay so the first value
the Greeks develop was idea of
freedom what is freedom freedom
represents an aarian society in which
everyone has the right to speak his mind
his not hers okay his M so every citizen
was considered um equal and that was the
basis for greatek
democracy everyone who has the right
everyone has the right to speak if
you're a
citizen okay now what is the Roman
counterpart thean counterpart is what we
called
Liberty and they sound similar but
they're actually very different concepts
freedom is the right to speak your mind
the right to live your life
liberty is the
respect for the
laws history and tradition
of your culture because that's what
enables you to be
free if we do not respect the laws it'
be
Anarchy also Liberty means basically no
King okay we will never allow a king
to rule us because he takes away our
Liberty what's interesting for us is the
modern Western concept is more aligned
with uh the Romans than the Greeks when
we think of freedom and liberty we think
of the
Roman idea not the Greek idea
okay so Liberty the the Roman word for
this is of course
libertas all right the second idea value
U of the Greeks is the idea of
udonia udonia is the pursuit of human
flourishing to be the best that you can
be to be better than your peers and to
win respect for Europe peers to seek
glory to seek honor so let's go back to
last semester and think about Achilles
in the in the Epic the
ilad Achilles was in Troy not to win
glory for the Greek people but to Wi
glory for himself he was extremely
selfish he was extremely
competitive and he was so
competitive that when he uh abandon the
battlefield he basically asked his
mother thetus the goddess to get Zeus
the high God to favor the Trojans okay
this is treason this is
sedition and for the Greeks this is good
because what's important is to win
udonia you in order to achieve udonia
can do anything because that's what
matters okay and the idea of udonia if
you think about it it's what led to
greatek creativity because everyone saw
society as a competition and they want
to be the
best okay but if you think about it also
leads to
corruption
um um and selfishness okay so the womans
didn't like udonia but instead their
highest virtue was the idea of repu
and this is where we get the word
Republic from Republic means for the
greater good for the public virtue so
what's important is not that you would
glory for yourself but to sacrifice
yourself for the greater good for the
good of
Rome that's what made you a good person
or the best person to fight and die for
Rome
and the third value for the Greeks that
matter was the idea of
er arit just means
Excellence so even though Achilles was a
jerk the Greek still admired him why
because he was a great soldier on the
battlefield he was fabulous he was
excellent and therefore he should be
admired okay the Romans didn't like this
okay they didn't want people to outshine
everyone else so they prefer the concept
of
piety obedience loyalty to your
fathers to Rome to the gods piety is
What
mattered the highest virtue in Rome is
not ER it is
piety and again a lot of Roman values
was developed in response to the Greeks
especially to the Athenians okay because
remember the Athenians in
they defeated the Persians and they the
Athenians became basically an Empire
they were a dominant military force in
the Mediterranean in the aan all all
that time but 80 years later 400 they
had been decimated they had been
destroyed they fought against Sparta in
the P pipan war and they
lost the Romans witnessed all this right
because they were just across across
from the Adriatic they knew all this and
so they were determined not to repeat
the mistakes of the
Athenians and that's why they develop a
system in opposition to the Greek the
Athenians the Athenians had democracy
and it was common wisdom at that time
that it was the democratic system that
caused the collapse of the Ean Empire
and in response the Romans develop a
system called The
Republic now there's a huge difference
between democracy and Republic they
sound the same and in today's world we
use these two concepts interchangeably
okay we say American democracy we say
American Republic it means the same
thing but back then democracy and
Republic were two opposing systems so
let me give you a example to show you
how different the system is okay so
democracy is basically one man one vote
it encourages competition encourages
debate it encourages free thought
Republic
is um to be ruled by institutions
basically the Senate okay
institutions by laws and by history or
tradition all right so what's the
difference all right let's pretend that
we're all going to go out for for lunch
today and each of us has a different
opinion I want to go to McDonald's Evo
wants to go and get dumpl Lings Eko
wants to go to Pizza who knows okay but
we all have different these different
opinions in a democracy we resolve this
issue by having debate I make my
argument for my idea then you all make
your argument for your ideas okay and
then we vote and the majority wins
simple
right okay a republic is different a
republic you make your decisions based
on tradition so for example today is
Thursday and for whatever reason we
don't know why but every Thursday we go
out to get
dumplings so guess what we just go and
get dumpling dings we don't ask why we
don't even know why we don't we we may
not even like dumplings it doesn't
matter what matters is you respect and
follow TR tradition set by your
fathers okay does that Mak
sense now what's
interesting is these two
systems have benefits and
consequences and it's the idea of the
Republic that
allows Rome to eventually conquer the
entire
Mediterranean and the reason why is the
idea of a republic solves a problem that
democracy cannot solve it's the idea of
CIP and
identity the way you organize your
Society is basically F citizenship okay
who gets to be a citizen who doesn't now
democracy
it's actually very hard to be a citizen
because if we are having debate and
competition we don't want others coming
into the system right there's four of us
in the classroom we debate but let's
just say we let in five other people and
these five other people all love noodles
guess what we're stuck going to Noodles
every day right so we don't want
newcomers and that's why the Athan
Empire fail the Empire had to fight
these wars to protect its Empire but in
each battle it had to lose soldiers even
if you win battles you have to lose
soldiers and it could not replenish
these soldiers because it did not want
foreigners to become
citizens does that make sense but in
Republic you do not have this problem
right if we are Republic we're all stuck
going to
Noodles uh every Thursday we let in 100
people doesn't matter we're all going
the noodles right it doesn't affect us
so the beauty of a republic is you can
allow immigrants and foreigners to come
into your system which allows you to
replenish your
military and they become citizens if
they are willing to fight for you and if
they're willing to follow your
Traditions your Customs your
history it's very similar in America
right in China how are you a Citi we
you're born here and both your parents
are Chinese and that's it okay there's
no other way to become a Chinese Chinese
citizen but in America you can immigrate
and just say I swear to obey the
Constitution I Swear to protect the
Constitution if you say those those
words you can become a US
citizen
okay so that's the power of the
Republic okay so let's let's talk about
some historical examples to illustrate
the difference between a democracy and a
republic well in the
democracy people understand polus or
society as a community of people okay so
the example is in 480 the Persians
invaded the Greek mainland and they were
about to attack Athens and there's no
way that Athens could
withstand the Persian Onslaught so what
do they do
well what they did was they
got uh onto their ships and they sailed
away the entire Athenian people the
entire city of Athens got onto the ships
and sailed
away and the persans were like wellit
you can't do that and the ath says yes
we can because as a community we can be
wherever we want we don't have to be in
Athens as long as we're a community we
will be
Athens we can leave Athens and go sell
to Africa and we will still be
Athens okay that's the idea of
community but the Romans didn't believe
that okay remember in
26 Hannibal comes and attacks the
Italian Peninsula he destroys and wipes
out all the Roman armies Rome has no
Army and at this point Rome has has
options it can
surrender or it can leave it cannot
leave
because to leave Rome would be to
abandon its
identity as a Roman people if you're a
republic you're the place does matter
once you leave the
place you
abandon the
values the culture the history that
makes you distinctly Roman so the women
said to Hano we will not surrender we
will fight to last man if you come and
attack us and Hannibal never did okay
and what's really funny about this
incident is it's really the proudest
moment in Roman history okay they were
up against impossible odds they had no
Army Hannibal was the greatest General
Ro in human history he had a huge Army
but the Roman people were willing to
make all the necessary sacrifices in
order to protect their
identity and their values and their
history they refuse let Rome
fall so every person whether it's woman
man or child would have taken arms and
attack and defended the city against
Hannibal and this was really the
highlight of the Republican
system it refuses to surrender because
to surrender would mean abandoning
it's
identity
okay so that's why Rome was able to
defeat all its enemies because the Roman
idea of studip was flexible if you're
willing to fight for Rome you could
become a citizen and as such Rome was
able to draw soldiers from all the all
of the P Italian
Peninsula um from 280 to
272 uh BCE there's something called the
p p Wars pyus who was uh a Greek king
came to the aid of the Greek colonies in
Italy okay these Greeks were complaining
and saying the Romans are bullying us
can someone please help us and build us
a Greek Empire so pyus comes and attacks
the Romans and he won every
battle the Romans were terrible soldiers
he had the best soldiers in the world
and he was winning every battle and at
one at at a certain point pyrus said
okay we're killing a lot of Romans but
if I win one more battle if I just win
one more battle I'm going to run out
soldiers so we have to
retreat okay and and this is because of
the idea of CIP the Greeks could not
replenish their forces whereas the
Romans
could
okay and this is what allowed for social
mobility and innovation in Rome the fact
that Rome was constantly fighting these
battles these wars against everyone and
learning from their mistakes and growing
as military
power eventually Rome comes in conflict
with Carthage and Carthage is at this
point um the greatest military sorry the
greatest naval power of of the
Mediterranean
Rome did not have a Navy it doesn't know
how to sell ships guess what it did what
did guess what happened they decid to
build a navy and they lost a lot of
battles against Carthage but again
because Rome was so persistent because
because Rome was not afraid to lose
soldiers eventually it overwhelmed
Carthage
okay so this is the reason why
eventually Rome was able to conquer the
entire Mediterranean
world no one could stop
Rome okay so by about 200
BCE um Rome was event was the greatest
military hegemon all that time and by
100 BC 100 years later it was an
Empire okay so are you guys clear any
questions so far before I
continue are you guys clear about about
this all
right but there's a
problem when Rome became an
Empire um a republic is not the same as
an Empire an Empire needed a bureaucracy
it needed an emperor you need a top-
down
system and that's in conflict with the
idea of a
republic where you have to obey the
history and and the institutions if
you're an Empire you have to absorb new
people into your culture but the Romans
didn't want to do that because it meant
giving up their own
culture right so this created a
contradiction it this Creed a
paradox and this will eventually lead to
a series of civil wars that really never
stops until Rome
collapses all right so to understand
this idea think about America today
America again it is the it is our
Humanity's greatest Empire it controls
the entire world basically it has 800
military bases around the world China
has about two
okay um it has no peer competitor but
there's one thing that you cannot say
about America if you go to Americans say
you guys an Empire you'll be shuted down
how dare you you say we're an Empire
there's nothing Imperial about us we're
Republic we're democracy we're not an
empire for whatever reason Americans
refuse to believe they an Empire it's
ridiculous and you have some silly
things for
example when Americans talk talk about
the Middle East right clearly America
wants to control the Middle East for its
resources but when you talk to
American academics American people for
whatever reason they believe American
Middle East policy is being controlled
by Israel a nation of 8 million people
in a desert Israel is able to control
the American
Empire and you're like that makes no
sense like how is it possible Israel to
control America but Americans really
believe this if you you talk about the
war in Ukraine there are a lot of
Americans who believe that it's the
European an who are making
America assist Ukraine it's all
European uh
manipulation okay and it's the silliest
thing it's like it's like what are you
talking about the Europeans are a vassel
state of America Israel is a vassel
state of
America and the reason why is Americans
cannot
understand that they're an Empire
because it goes against their idea of
themselves as democracy as a
republic all right this is what we call
the word for this is called
cognitive
dissonance all right you guys have
should have studied this in Psychology
okay but it's but it's impossible to
have for your mind to hold in place two
cons ideas America cannot both be a
republic and an Empire therefore it's
Republic and don't ever mention the word
empire okay and guess what the Romans
had the same problem they could not
conceive of themselves as an Empire and
they refused to be an Empire even though
they were an Empire and this led to lots
of civil wars and conflicts between Rome
and the people around
Rome okay so the example is that from 91
to
89 Rome F something called the social
war remember this is after Rome became
an Empire it it now has no peir
competitor it has no adversary so now it
starts fight to fight Wars among its own
people the social war was fought between
Rome and its Italian allies or neighbors
for most of its history Rome was drawing
soldiers from its
allies and after Rome became an Empire
its allies uh Italian allies rightfully
said listen we fought for you for
decades we've lost many men we demand to
be given Sinners ship and and Rome said
no and so they fought a Civil War and
Rome lost the Civil War because guess
what its military was from the Italian
Peninsula okay so it could not defeat
its allies and and so it had to make its
allies into Roman
citizens okay and Rome
will'll keep on doing this where it has
all these subject people the subject
people rebel because they want
citizenship but again for Rome what
matters is the protection of its
cultural identity and you give CIP to
too many people that the loots your
cultural identity okay they were afraid
that Rome will stop being Rome and that
led to conflicts throughout its history
and it never really
ended okay
so um you can't ever use the word Empire
Emperor in Rome then the question then
is wait didn't wasn't um Augustus
Caesar uh after the battle of aium the
first Roman
Emperor uh no okay the idea of an Empire
the idea of an emperor the idea that uh
Augustus Caesar was the first emperor is
something that later historians
um decided on the Romans did not see
themselves as an Empire okay and
Augustus Caesar did not see himself as
an emperor the word he used the word the
the Romans use is the idea of
PRP okay PRP just means enroll in Latin
First Citizen we are still equals mean
Senators okay but I'm just a bit better
than you I'm the first among equals
and this is where we get the English
word Prince
from and Augustus Caesar did not see him
see himself as building an empire he saw
himself as saving the
[Music]
Republic
okay
now now what's important to understand
is that August Caesar was considered the
greatest Roman
leader because he ruled for 50 plus
years his was a very stable regime and
the reason why if you recall from last
semester is he was the hear to Julius
Caesar and there's tremendous regret and
guilt among the Roman people for having
killed Julius Caesar and so they allowed
his hear his son um to be king king or
Emperor without much opposition that was
not true for his
um his hears okay so after Augustus
Cesar died all these Civil Wars and
conflicts that were suppressed were now
fermented again okay and this now would
now lead to a massive period of Civil
Wars um
now are understanding of Roman history
comes a lot from Roman historians
themselves specifically two individuals
Livy and um
tacitus and we
basically listen to what they wrote for
for example we so what we mean by that
is we take their word as gospel we take
the word as truth but what we we need to
recognize is they were senators okay
part of the nobility who hated the
Emperors who hated the princeps so they
did whatever they could in order to make
the Emperors look bad okay so there were
four
Emperors uh sorry there were three
Emperors after death of Augustus
tiberias kiga and Nero and they were all
made to look look very very bad
especially uh Nero and
kiga and
okay so let me give you an example of
this so um after Augustus dies Augustus
names two people here to his legacy okay
the first is
tiberias who
becomes the emperor Tiberius is not his
son it is his adopted son okay so that's
that is a Roman tradition where uh you
can adopt someone outside the family to
be your here okay and that um and
then after tiaris died um Augustus
anointed jericus to be his successor and
germanicus was
considered um an extremely talented and
capable leader okay the problem though
is that Tiberius who is now Emperor
didn't like the fact
that
jericus was appointed his successor he
wanted to anoint his own
successor okay so Tiberius what he did
that was very sneaky was he got he made
a man named
sanus the head of the uh ptan guard and
the patan guard was basically the secret
police of Rome and so Janice because he
was very ambitious he start to kill not
just germanicus but everyone in
germanicus family shanus wanted to be
the he to
tiberias and then after um sanus was
done killing everyone basically in
janica's
family tiberious had him
killed okay this is a very common uh
pattern in imperial history okay um
after sanus was killed there's a per of
sanis allies his children were killed
and everyone who supports sanis was
interrogated by the Senate and put to
death and most of these
people claim innocence I had nothing to
do withan I was forced into an alliance
with sanis okay now there's one person a
Roman noal man named Marcus
tanus who in 31 CE he appeared before
the for his
trial and he decided on a different
strategy everyone else before him claim
I had nothing to do with sanis and the
sen didn't believe them and they were
all killed okay so Marcus tannus tries
to different strategy and this is
recounted in the history book annals by
tacitus who was writing about 100 years
later
okay and this is what Marcus trenis
argues he argues
yes I was his friend in fact I tried
very best to be his
friend why because suus had the favor of
the emperor because if I wanted to get
anything done if I if I want to become
wealthy I had to become a friend of su
Jenis and why did I do this and why was
this right because it is not up to me to
question or or think about why sanus is
a friend of the emperor all I need to
know was the emperor favor
sanis and is my duty to obey the emperor
and therefore I became his
friend okay that was his logic now let's
look at what tus wrote okay and it's
really uh one of the most striking
paragraphs in the history okay but but
this is Marcus Serena's defense of
himself before Senate and the emperor it
is not ours to ask whom you the emperor
exalt above his fellow or why you the
gods have made Sovereign Arbiter of
things okay it's not my place to ever
question the
emperor if the emperor made
shanus his right-hand man I now must
also obey
Janis if the emperor wants me to to
marry a dog I will go marry a
dog to search to us has been left the
glory of obedience to search out the
hidden thoughts of the emperor and the
designs he may shape in secret is
unlawful and dangerous nor would the
Searcher necessarily find okay what does
this mean it means the emperor is God he
has a secret design he has a secret
logic that we could never know and
because we're too
stupid and if we try to figure out we
will be breaking the laws of Rome and
the
universe and we could only get into
trouble so it's not up to me to question
the emperor it's it is only my duty to
obey the
emperor the firmness of the speech okay
so he's he's finished speaking defending
himself in front of the Senate and this
is how the emperor and Senate respond to
this speech the firmness of the speech
he speaks with conviction okay and the
fact that a man had been discovered to
utter what the world was
thinking made so powerful on an
impression that his accusers were
penalized by banishment or death okay so
rather than punish this man the Senate
punish his accusers his enemies why
because they had found a man to speak
the truth about the world
the emperor was in
command we had to obey the emperor and
they wanted to make a role model out of
him and therefore they killed all his
enemies and let him go and rewarded him
lavishly
okay now this was
written in
contrast to Roman
history this marks a radical departure
from Roman history remember
in
9 the Republic was founded because they
threw out the king in response the king
organized his allies the truans and they
marched on Rome and Rome was
surrounded
by um a huge
Army and there was nothing Rome could do
about it so a young nobleman named
muus went to the Senators and and
propose a daring plan to assassinate the
king he swims across the Tyber he goes
into the camp
of uh the enemy and he's captured he's
interrogated by the king and musia says
we Romans have sworn to kill all
Kings and to show that he's serious he
puts his hand into a fire and he burns
he burns his hand in front of the king
and the king is scared so he runs away
okay so this story shows us the nature
of the Roman character Romans hate Kings
Romans will always disobey Kings Romans
will always find a way to kill
Kings and this speech shows us that the
Roman character has fundamentally
changed because of
Empire okay so Romans throughout most of
its history the r people have been
grappling with what it means to be Roman
and how to protect this precious
identity
now we
know that even though tacus wrote this
the Roman identity didn't really
change how do we know
this how do we know that even though
tasa says okay Empire changed the Roman
identity it didn't really change how do
we know this
because he's writing about this
right he's writing about this he's
telling us that the Roman identity
changed because of
Empire well if the ran identity really
changed people wouldn't know it changed
it's only because people are resisting
the change in nature the change in
character that people
appreciate what tus is writing and tus
is is really saying that oh that Empire
it's gone now because the new emperor
has restored the
Republic okay so throughout its history
Rome was constant in a battle between
Empire and Republic and every new
emperor believed that he was restoring
the Republic but then his but then
someone else would come along and says
no he was the dictator he was the EMP he
was the emperor
okay so this was a conflict
throughout Roman
history and so now the question we go on
to the second question which is all
right um how did The
Empire fall okay well the standard
explanation is that eventually Rome
became too
corrupt and this is the explanation
provided by most Roman
historians as well as the very as as
well as the famous British historian
Edward Gibbon in his most famous work
history of the decline and fall of the
Roman Empire okay it's corruption it's
because the the Romans became more like
the Greeks or like the Persians they
started to appreciate the luxury
decadence and Corruption of Empire more
okay and the expl and the the the
explanation is that over time you got
all these dramatic Invaders from the
steps remember the steps is where the Y
people come from these vovs are being
pushed up by the Huns okay so remember
the steps um is really this
massive competitive wh poor hurricane
that makes people more more aggressive
and more aggressive tribes will push out
less aggressive tribes and these people
are forced to go into Europe and over
time the Romans are trying to absorb
them into their empire by making them
soldiers or uh by um giving them land
okay but over time this pure
population um will force the Empire to
collapse okay and that's the center
explanation I want to make a different
argument my argument is is this
it really has to do again with the idea
of CIP and
identity throughout most of its history
Imperial Rome has been struggling with
this identity
issue and then at some point an emperor
came along and said screw this we no
longer want want to be Republic we want
to be an
Empire okay and the way he resolved this
issue is in
212 the emperor kakala issued the idct
of car kala which made
everyone in Roman Empire a citizen so he
basically destroyed the idea of
citizenship if everyone can be a citizen
Citizenship means nothing before you
have to fight for Rome you have to die
for Rome in order to become a citizen
you have to believe in the Customs the
history the tradition of Rome to become
a citizen you have to fight for it it
was it was valuable it was in fact it
was the most valuable thing in the world
for people but now everyone got it so
it's absolutely
worthless okay and because everyone was
not a Roman
citizen there was now no more Roman
identity it was now a clean slate the
Emperors were now were now no longer
bounded by tradition or
history by institutions like the Senate
and so now they could build the Imperial
bureaucracy and this Imperial
bureaucracy uh will replace the Republic
and the major change is in 3:30 the
emperor Constantine will move the
capital from Rome to a place called B
banum which will become the bantin
Empire or the Eastern Roman
Empire okay we'll talk about this next
class but this is something that was
Unthinkable how could you move the heart
and center and soul of the Empire from
Rome to somewhere else was Unthinkable
if if if
to be Roman was meant to die for Rome
but now the capital was somewhere
else okay and so when so this marks the
basically the end of Rome as a cultural
identity as a cultural Beacon okay this
marked really the death of the history
of Rome okay does that make sense to you
guys okay now historians argue about
this and historian Ians argue when the
Roman Empire fell all right but the cons
consensus is 476 when a German warlord
uh deposed The Last Emperor named Romus
Augustus okay but I disagree I believe
that it really happened in 212 when Rome
announced everyone could be a um
citizen okay and we'll talk more about
this next class when we get to the bis
Empire and okay so any questions so far
I I know this is a lot but we'll try to
clarify a lot of the issues over the
next few classes okay but you any
questions now please ask any questions
so far about
this is this clear to you guys
yeah pass this
okay all right let me clarify okay tdus
was a Senator okay the senator was
always in conflict with the emperor okay
the senator the Senate okay uh sorry let
me clarify about Senate the Senate was
basically the Roman aristocracy it was
where the ruling families of Rome sat
and they were supposed to be in charged
of the Empire and the emperor was
basically the CEO okay he was basically
in charge of managing the Empire but it
was a senate That was supposed to make
the decisions in reality it was the
Emperor who was in charge because the
emperor controlled the Army and he
controlled the ptan guard which is secet
police so he could kill Senators who
disobeyed him okay and this was always a
very complex
relationship so when tacus again who is
a senator who who comes from one of the
leite
families of Rome when he's writing about
the history of the uh Roman Empire from
the time of Augustus to Nero he's trying
to paint them in a very bad light okay
because he's trying to tell us Emperors
are bad what's good is a
senate and and that's why he's producing
the speech because if you're a Roman
citizen and you read this speech by
Marcus trus you are appalled you're
disgusted we're Romans we hate Kings we
do not obey we fight we do not
surrender okay so this speech goes
against the
very heart and soul of what it means to
be Roman and that's and and and that's
why tasis is writing this and saying you
see what Empire does to the Roman
character it corrupts us it destroys us
it weakens us and therefore we must
resist the emperor and protect the
Senate okay doesn't make sense guys okay
so so thanks for that okay so so I
apologize because I'm running through a
lot of history in a short amount of time
so I'm missing a lot of important
details what's really important for you
to understand is in the Republic the
Senate is in charge okay meaning the
ruling houses the aristocracy in charge
but in an Empire the emperor is in
charge but Rome never resolve this issue
who's who should be in charge the senate
or the emperor and it changes over time
okay sometimes the sen is in charge
sometimes the emperor's in charge but
they all believe they're protecting the
Republic and this creates conent
dissonance okay and that it creates a
lot of
confusion and then in 212 the emperor
said screw this let's this be an Empire
I don't want the say anymore okay and
this and this begins a process of
creating the banum
Empire which does not have the idea of a
Roman
character okay
did did you have a question
Echo basically are the
senes exactly yeah um the Senate is
filled by again members of the ruling
houses and what's interesting about
about the system is it's almost like a
federal system I'm not sure you know
what a federal system is but the emperor
is in charge of the army he's in charge
of the secret police in Rome but the
Senators are actually in charge of the
provinces so basically each Senator gets
a certain Province to um uh control okay
um so it's like the United States where
Governors are in charge of a state the
president is in charge of the
nation Okay now what's important for you
to understand is technically each state
is independent each state has its own
Army has its own basically legal
system and it agrees to be part of the
federal system which the president is
part of and this is very similar to the
Roman system okay not exactly but it's
very similar all
right okay any more questions before I
conclude okay so my um the last question
I want to look at today is what's the
legacy of the Roman Empire or the
Republic and the answer is we still live
in the Roman
world even though we like to think that
we are heavily influenced by the
Greeks it's institutions of Rome that
we've
inherited okay so the idea of the
political system the legal system the
cultural
system it's something that the Americans
basically copy and
pasted the Roman the American system is
very very Roman and right now of course
America controls the world and therefore
it's able to disseminate Roman values
and
culture okay and throughout the semester
we will be examining how Rome came to
control the cultural framework of
Western
Civilization okay because even though
Rome collapsed and Rome the character of
Rome is now dead the Roman Legacy is
still there and all these people
fighting these Warlords okay these
basically German Warlords they're now
going to fight the civil war after the
death of Rome they're claiming to be to
be carrying on the legacy of Rome okay
from their perspective Rome has not died
but Rome has spread
out and these Warlords will ad a lot of
Roman practices and these Warlords will
build uh the culture that will give rise
to new nations called France Germany
Britain basically the European World
okay so that's the legacy of
Rome that's why it's important to study
role what lessons Okay what lessons can
we draw from Rome
well one really important lesson that we
have to learn here is the idea of
CIP and
identity you cannot be a
strong and coherent Nation if you do not
have a strong cultural identity that's
why the Romans were so insistent on
protecting their identity against the
Greeks against um
foreigners okay and this is important
because if you look at the Western world
today immigration identity and and CIP
are huge political issues uh I'm a can
citizen I was I I grew up in
Canada and over the past 10 years the
population of Canada went from like 30
million to 40
million these 10 new this 10 million
people are all foreigners we have no
sense of Canadian identity they have no
interest in being Canadian they just
want a better life for
themselves 40% of Canadians now were e
were either foreign born or have a
parent who is a foreign
born so there's no more identity and
this is a problem why because United
States Trump wants to take over Canada
and make Canada into the into the F 51st
state okay and this's a problem because
Canadians don't want to resist against
this 10 years ago all Canadians would
say nope but now you have 10 million
Canadians who are very happy to join the
United States because it means more
economic opportunities for them right
they don't care about cultural identity
so without controlling immigration you
as a nation can't be coherent and you
will cease to exist over time and the
same is true in um the same is true of
what's happening in Britain throughout
the Western World basically they're
Landing too many immigrants and they're
deluding their own cultural identity so
over the next 10 20 years a lot a lot of
people are predicting massive civil wars
in the western world as these nations
grapple with the consequences of
unlimited immigration these past 10
years okay so that's one thing to think
about one lesson that that we can learn
from the Roman Roman world ciip does
matter make it hard to become a citizen
make it valuable make it an honor to be
a citizen and your nation will be strong
if ciip is cheap if you can just buy it
then it's worthless and you will cease
to be culturally
coherent and eventually you will cease
to exist as a
nation okay so that's the first major
lesson second major lesson about Rome is
it went out because it was a aggressive
Nation but once you went out against
your enemies this aggression has to go
somewhere and it usually turns
inward okay and that's why Rome kept on
fighting these Civil Wars amongst itself
and the same is true for America America
is a nation that worships aggression for
example um think think about the number
of guns in America there's like I I
don't know the exact statistics but
there's about 400 million guns in
America America only has 300 million
people there are more guns than there
are people in America it worships Ence
also think about this the most popular
sport in America is American football
there's only one nation in the world
that plays American football and that's
America No Other Nation plays it why
because it is barbaric you you literally
have people trying to kill each other
for the entertainment and pleasure of
Spectators it's
barbaric um I'm not sure if you know
this but after 5 years of are playing
football these athletes their brains are
mush and they commit suicide at age 30
or
35 okay so so it's no different from
Gladiator sport in Rome which Romans
loved okay so what so America is a
violent Society if it cannot turn its
violence outside it will turn violence
it will direct its the violence and
aggression inwards so I think within the
next 10 years America will most likely
start a war probably against
Iran okay so I'm predicting within the
next 5 years America will start a war
against Iran probably sooner and then
America will start a Civil War as
well so Civil War does not mean um two
sides fighting against each other it
just means that there'll be a lot of
political killings assassinations a lot
of violence in America okay based on
religious political
differences all right so that's a second
lesson to learn from Rome aggression and
violence will allow you will allow you
to defeat your enemies once you do this
violence and aggression will turn
inwards
okay and the third lesson that we can
learn from Rome is again no societies
are
stable everything changes over time so
even though Rome was the dominant
superpower of its time it's still
collapse and the same is true for
America
today so the world will change and it
always
changes okay so next class we will look
at the Roman Empire which is basically
the Byzantine
Empire okay any questions about today's
class
are you guys
clear okay great so I will see you uh
next class